hi guys and welcome back to Med
simplified in this video we are going to
talk about 7 foods that are very good
for your heart
I'm Dr Umar and let's begin a healthy
heart is essential for your overall
health and well-being a healthy heart
can pump blood effectively which helps
to deliver oxygen and nutrients to the
body's tissue and organs this can
improve energy levels reduce fatigue and
improve the overall quality of your life
heart disease also known as
cardiovascular disease is a term used to
describe a range of conditions that
affect the heart and the blood vessels
these conditions can include coronary
artery disease heart failures
arrhythmias and water disorders
morbidity refers to the incidence or
prevalence of a disease or condition
while mortality refers to the number of
deaths caused by the disease
heart disease is a leading cause of both
morbidity as well as mortality worldwide
and its impact is growing and it varies
by age sex and geography according to
the World Health Organization
cardiovascular disease is responsible
for an estimated 17.9 million deaths per
year accounting for 31 of all Global
deaths
in the United States heart disease is
the leading cause of death for both men
and women causing around 655
000 deaths per year
the morbidity due to heart disease is
also high with millions of people living
with condition and experiencing a range
of symptoms and complications some of
the common symptoms of heart disease can
include chest pain discomfort shortness
of breath fatigue and palpitations
complications can include heart attacks
stroke heart failure and arrhythmias the
impact of heart disease on morbidity and
mortality can be reduced through
lifestyle modifications such as regular
exercise a healthy diet avoiding smoking
and managing stress as well as through
Medical Treatments such as medication
surgery and other interventions diet
plays a crucial role in heart health
consuming a healthy diet is associated
with a lower risk of developing
cardiovascular disease while an
unhealthy diet can increase the risk
here are some of the impacts of diet on
heart health
consuming a diet high in sodium can
increase blood pressure levels which is
a major risk factor for heart disease
similarly consuming a diet high in
saturated and trans fats can increase
cholesterol levels in the blood which is
another risk factor for heart disease
eating a diet that is low in saturated
and trans fats and high in fiber can
help to lower cholesterol levels and
reduce the risk of heart disease
consuming a diet high in calories and
low in essential nutrients can lead to
weight gain and opacity which is another
risk factor for heart disease eating a
healthy diet that is low in calories and
high in essential nutrients can help to
maintain a healthy weight and reduce the
risk of heart disease so the bottom line
here is that we should take very good
care of the heart and the blood vessels
because these are very essential parts
of our body and eating a diet that is
rich in good nutrients plays a vital
role in improving heart health as well
as avoiding the foods that can promote
heart diseases like foods rich in sodium
trans fats and high calories they also
play a vital role for maintaining a
healthy heart
now let's talk about seven foods that
are very good for your heart number one
oats
oats are a great source of fiber and
have been shown to lower the LDL
cholesterol levels also known as a bad
cholesterol you can enjoy them in the
form of oatmeal granola or even in baked
goods like oatmeal cookies
a study published in the American
journal of clinical nutrition found that
consuming oatmeal or oat bran can
significantly reduce total cholesterol
levels by five to ten percent and LDL
cholesterol levels by seven to ten
percent
number two salmon
salmon is a fatty fish that is rich in
omega-3 fatty acids these healthy fats
have been shown to reduce inflammation
in the body and improve your overall
heart health
aim for at least two servings of fatty
fish per week and you can enjoy them
grilled baked or even in sushi a
scientific review of 2500 people found
that consuming omega-3 fatty acids from
fish such as salmon can significantly
reduce the risk of cardiovascular
disease particularly in those with high
triglyceride levels
number three berries berries like
strawberries blueberries and raspberries
are packed with antioxidants that have
been shown to reduce inflammation in the
body and improve your overall heart
health you can enjoy them fresh or
frozen in smoothies or even as a healthy
dessert
a study published in the American
journal of clinical nutrition found that
consuming blueberries for eight weeks
can significantly improve your
endothelial function of your heart which
is a marker of heart health berries like
strawberries blueberries and raspberries
have Rich antioxidants in them like
anthocyanins and flavonoids these
antioxidants have been shown to reduce
inflammation in the body which is a
major risk factor for heart disease
number four nuts nuts like almonds
walnuts and pistachios are a great
source of healthy fats fiber as well as
proteins they have been shown to improve
cholesterol levels and reduce
inflammation in the body
you can enjoy them as a snack in trail
mix or even in salads
a study published in the Journal of
American College of Cardiology found
that consuming nuts can reduce the risk
of coronary heart disease by up to 37
and multiple Studies have found that
eating a diet rich in nuts helps to
lower the LDL cholesterol or the bad
cholesterol and it also increases the
good cholesterol which is known as the
HDL cholesterol number five dark
chocolate
dark chocolate is a delicious treat
that's also good for your heart it's
high in antioxidants that have been
shown to improve blood flow in the
vessels and lower the blood pressure
just make sure to choose dark chocolate
with at least 70 cocoa solids
a meta-analysis of 15 studies found that
consuming dark chocolate can
significantly reduce blood pressure
particularly in those with hypertension
apart from reducing blood pressure it
has been found that eating dark
chocolate improves your HDL levels and
decreases the LDL levels of cholesterol
in your body
inflammation is a major risk factor for
heart disease
and a study published in the American
Journal of nutrition found that
consuming dark chocolate can help to
reduce inflammation in adults with
overweight or obesity the study found
that those who consume dark chocolate
had lower levels of inflammatory markers
in their blood number six leafy green
vegetables leafy greens like spinach
kale and collard greens are packed with
vitamins minerals and antioxidants
they have been shown to improve heart
health by reducing inflammation in the
body and improving your overall blood
pressure you can enjoy them in salads
smoothies or even as a sauteed dish a
study published in the British medical
journal found that consuming one extra
serving of leafy greens per day can
reduce the risk of coronary heart
disease by 16 leafy green vegetables are
a rich source of vitamins and minerals
like vitamin K magnesium and potassium
these nutrients are important for
maintaining healthy blood pressure
levels and preventing heart disease
leafy greens are low in calories and
high in fiber which can help to prevent
weight gain and maintain a healthy
weight maintaining a healthy weight is
very important for reducing the risk of
heart disease
number seven avocados
avocado is a great source of healthy
fats that have been shown to improve
cholesterol levels and reduce
inflammation in the body
you can enjoy it as a spread on toast in
salads or even as a substitute for
mayonnaise
a study published in the Journal of
American Heart Association found that
consuming one avocado per day as a part
of moderate fat diet can significantly
improve cholesterol levels and reduce
the risk of cardiovascular disease and
another study published in the journal
of clinical hypotension found that
consuming avocados can help to lower
blood pressure in adults with
hypertension
the study found that those who consumed
avocados for six weeks had significantly
lower systolic blood pressure than those
who did not consume avocado avocado is a
unique fruit that is packed with healthy
fats fibers and nutrients that have been
shown to improve heart health it can
improve cholesterol levels blood
pressure vascular function and reduce
inflammation so the next time you're
looking for a healthy and delicious
addition to your meals try incorporating
more avocados in your everyday meals in
conclusion we have discussed seven
different foods that have been shown to
benefit heart health berries leafy
greens fatty fish nuts whole grains
avocado and dark chocolate all have
unique properties that can improve
cholesterol levels blood pressure reduce
inflammation and improve the overall
heart health incorporating these Foods
into your diet is a simple and effective
way to support a healthy heart
remember a healthy diet is just one
aspect of a heart healthy lifestyle
regular physical activity Stress
Management and avoiding smoking are also
very important for maintaining a healthy
heart thank you for watching and we hope
you found this information helpful if
you did you can always make a small
donation on our patreon page it really
helps us to keep making free health
videos like this and also don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for more
health and wellness tips see you guys in
the next video take care goodbye